- Alright, so we're gonna dig into lessons
from the leaders in Agentic AI.
And so my name's Roger Primo,
I lead corporate strategy
for IBM and a lot of our strategy,
we've been on this journey
for the last several years.
Going back to 2020,
we declared this hybrid
cloud and AI strategy.
And obviously with cloud we also know
so much being here at re:Invent.
In 2020 we got this question
of why AI, why not blockchain,
why not VR, all these things.
I think today everybody
understands the necessity of AI
and I'm just gonna try and
get these slides to start.
Let's see if it goes.
And what we're seeing in, I
lead our corporate strategy team
and what we've looked
at is this technology
and understanding
how does it compare versus
prior generations technology.
And I think there's a
lot of buzz in the market
around agentic AI.
People have heard so much.
I think the message, if I could
leave anyone with today is
if you're starting, keep going
and we're gonna hear real
examples from companies
that have applied this technology
to change their business for the better.
But if you're one of the many
that MIT put out the
famous study that only 5%
of companies are getting value from AI,
if you're one of that 95%,
that's not getting value,
the time is now to start changing that
because the companies that are starting
to use this technology, the
advantages are compounding.
And we're seeing real examples
inside IBM's business, in
our client's businesses,
in the market where agentic AI is far more
disruptive than any technology
generation that's coming before.
It will come faster, it'll
touch more businesses,
more categories, more
industries than any technology
disruption we've seen before.
And so if you are among that 95%
that haven't truly turned GenAI
and now agentic into value,
to me the real question from
that MIT study is not, why
are 95% not getting value?
It's what are the 5% that are doing
and how can we learn from them
before they put the laggards
of adoption outta business?
If I had one framework to
think about this, we've used
this idea of raising the
floor and breaking the ceiling
and we'll have Mark come up
in a second talking about
both of those working together.
But this technology changes.
Your best process today is
your worst process tomorrow.
And I'd say that when my
corporate strategy teams
looked around the world at success cases
and adopting this technology,
what's fascinating is there's
almost no industry sector
that's not among the ones that
have gotten value from it.
Because in those raise
the floor use cases,
there's real value and
we'll talk about it.
The main patterns are in
things like customer service,
back office, and code development.
Every company in the world has customers.
Every company in the
world has a back office.
Today, most companies
in the world write code.
The patterns are there to create value.
I think what I've seen as a
failure mode is companies take
on an exotic break the ceiling use case,
but they haven't solved
things like data access
and security skills in their business
to implement this technology.
Trying to burden the creative
use case that should come
for your business with
these technical challenges
sometimes becomes too heavy.
So start with a lot of
those proven patterns.
Or if you're an innovator
like Mark, you can start
by breaking the ceiling if
you really have the vision
and persistence to drive through it.
To me, this metaphor at
the bottom of the page,
I think we all know about Moore's law.
I think agents reduce
this translation barrier.
So many times where we've been
anchored in human processes
and it's what slows down
business innovation.
The agents don't care
about your prior processes.
They'll learn how to deliver
for the best outcomes
if you can create the evaluation
frameworks that tell them where to go.
And to me, the translation barriers
between Moore's Law
and the actual outcomes
for business shrink.
And so I think it means that this cliche
of every company being
a technology company
has never been more true
than this agentic era.
If I just broke down, how
does this come to life?
Let's take a look at
the classics of people,
process and systems.
And while there's a lot that
we can say on all these topics,
I just say two things.
On process, it is this notion
of optimizing to outcomes,
not processes.
If I look at prior generations
of digital transformation
or cloud transformation, one of the things
that held companies back is
they're anchored in today's
workflow and they're
incremental on improving
on what they do today.
The agents don't have that anchoring.
If we tell them the right
outcomes to optimize for,
they will shatter today's
processes that hold us back.
They'll find new creative
ways to implement,
they'll deliver value in
ways that a traditional kind
of human driven engineering
process may have never found.
On the right side of the page,
this is how we've implemented a lot
of it in IBM's business and
I'll spend a minute on that.
But this technology touches
every layer of the business.
At the base, individual
productivity workers,
this is part of the toolkit
of the modern worker.
I grew up early in my career,
I sat next to the former CEO
of my employer and he'd kind
of come up in the 70s and 80s,
and every day he had
his assistant print out
all of his emails and then he'd read them
and he'd scroll notes on him
and his assistant would
type those back in.
If we're not the adopt,
if he didn't adopt email
and it held back how he'd
communicate in a modern era.
If we're not all the users
of this technology every day,
we talk a lot internally at
IBM of if the first attempt
of using the tool, when you prompt it,
it doesn't give you the right answer.
Learn how to prompt it to
get better on the next wave.
And if it still gives
you the wrong answer,
after a couple of attempts,
pass that feedback to the development team
so they can meet, create a better
experience in the next wave of it.
But every knowledge worker has to know how
to use this technology.
At the center layer on
the right side of it.
If we think about end-to-end
business processes,
there's so much optimization
there that can happen.
And it creates ways for
if it's your CFO, CHRO,
et cetera, ways for them to optimize
and create new ways
of serving the business
in their various domains.
And inside our business
we see general managers
and CEOs that are using that
insights and decisions layer,
being able to look at
the cumulative effect
of that generative AI deployed
to the individual worker,
to enterprise processes.
And then being able to look
at it in an integrated fashion
across the entire business.
So CEO can ask the question of
how do I make my business better?
And the agents get up to work on asking
that question in a way that
touches the entire business
and comes back with an
answer sometimes in minutes.
Versus if we were to ask
individual leaders come back
with 10 ideas on how we become better,
that's often a multi-month
process in so many businesses.
So the rate and pace of that
top of the pyramid of insights
and decisions works so much faster
and so much broader than it did before.
Since we're at re:Invent,
I want to talk a little bit
about the technical foundation of this,
because there's so much
innovation occurring
across AWS, across the
edge, at data centers,
across other cloud providers,
across SaaS applications.
One simple thing I'd leave you
with from a technical perspective is one
of the things we know about agents is
that if I give agents more information
to make decisions on and
I give them more tools
and places they can take
action across my business,
they'll be more impactful
if I give them that breadth
of access.
And for most organizations in the world,
that means giving them
access to learn from data
that lives in those SaaS applications,
lives in AWS, lives in other clouds
and the ability to call tools
across all of those environments.
So we have to think differently about
how we platform engineer
our technical architecture
to provide that type of
access to the agents.
I'd also think if we think
about the IT environments
and the application environments
that our employees work in,
I'll talk about the IBM example,
but we swapped out our
core HR system at IBM.
All of our work was done
through an agentic interface.
Most employees in the company didn't know
that we changed our HR
provider behind the scenes
'cause they'd become so
accustomed to interacting
with a conversational interface.
That interface of work is
changing from the application
to the conversation that
touches any application
or data in your business
regardless of where it lives.
So thinking about that way of working
and the technical layer
and how you think about your application
and technology environment
is critically important.
And then the last thing
I'll say is the data journey
is incredibly important.
So accessing both data quality,
data access, data permission
and security, how we think about
things like identity across
this environment so that
when an agent in one part
of your environment can have
a conversation with the other
and they can know that
that agent has permission
to have that conversation.
There's a lot of important
technical architecture work
that has to be done on this
foundation as a prerequisite
for success at scale with agentic.
That doesn't mean you can't
do pilots in specific areas,
but I think re-looking at
platform engineering in the agentic
context is critically important.
As an IBM example, we
wanna be the exemplars
of using this technology in our business.
We wanna be a best practice
example so we can feed it back
to our product teams
and our consulting teams
to help our clients, but then
also to improve our business.
And so all of this data
is publicly reported
in our audited financials.
So this is kind of the
real data behind it.
But we have raised our floor
and we're in the process
of breaking our ceiling.
In IBM by the end of this year,
the run rate of our business will be
four and a half billion dollars better
than it was just three or four years ago
based on a GenAI based
transformation of how we operate.
We've added enormous productivity into our
back office functions.
So today I do my HR work
in a tool called ASK HR,
which is basically an agentic interface
to those HR technologies
I discussed before.
The same is true in
finance, IT, procurement,
so many of the back office
functions that there's
so much data in so many businesses
that you can learn how to do it.
If it's customer service
and in code we're seeing
just new ways to innovate.
And I think those are well known in
many areas of the industry.
If I think about breaking
the ceiling, we're innovating
how we do consulting with something called
IBM Consulting Advantage built upon
our orchestrate platform,
which is our agentic orchestration layer.
We've changed how we do customer service.
We've built our own GenAI native IDE
that's driving both
productivity internally
and with a set of customers that are part
of the private preview of it.
So we're seeing both the
ability to fundamentally change
how we operate and how productive we are
and changing what we bring
to market with our clients.
The last thing I'd say
is these feed each other.
We're not taking all
the productivity money
and just distributing
it out to shareholders.
We're reinvesting that in innovation so
that break the ceiling can go faster.
And I do think for most
organizations in that room,
some version of that pattern,
it probably applies for you as well.
But there's hope. So
this has been so hard.
95% are failing.
There are some of these exemplars
and obviously this conference
is filled with a number
of people that'll talk about that success.
But if I had to synthesize
across the companies
that we've looked at
that have beaten the odds
and gotten value from this,
and I source it a lot from
our internal examples as well.
I think it comes from a set
of vision and leadership,
alignment from the top all the way down
to the individual employee
that's to use this technology.
It comes this notion of
purposeful processes.
I'll just say the kind
of anti-pattern there is.
So many companies I've spoken with,
they have a hundred, a
thousand GenAI pilots going
that live in disparate places.
But if they're in disparate places,
that means that the data quality work for
that one use case doesn't help the data
quality work for the next.
Thinking about these as
end-to-end processes so
that the work compounds, the
technology platform integrates
and the benefit accrues in
a much more systematic way,
we see as a pattern that
continues to be true.
Investing deeply in data
readiness and data quality.
We've spent a lot of time
working on our view of a customer
of an employee, of a product
to better represent it both
for traditional data analytics
and for generative AI.
Data quality is always a good
idea in so many businesses.
I think now there's so much
more of an agentic prize
to be gotten that if particular
data quality initiatives
couldn't make it over the line in your
organization a year or two ago,
today, the ROI is probably there
because there's so much more value
to be created with agentic.
The fourth is spending time
on that technical foundation.
And I talked about it, but
those little use cases that
so many companies went
down in their hundreds
or thousands of pilots, if
that one small use case has
to figure out the data security
and access challenge all unto itself,
it kind of crushes under its weight.
So there has to be this
technical maturity that is paired
with the use cases that you
pursue to be able to make sure
that we don't burden one use case
with the technical work that'll
benefit the entire business.
And the last thing I'd say
is there is a new development
model that's emerged and
we've worked to codify
what we've done internally.
I'll talk about a little bit.
We've worked with Anthropic to publish
what we call the age agentic
development lifecycle.
But the traditional software
development lifecycle,
which is very kind of linear,
doesn't lend itself as well here.
So it's much more of an
optimization learning cycle,
both in development and in production
that we think when you get to
that point of understanding
that begin with evaluations.
And those evaluations
mean the business outcome,
they mean the model cost
you're willing to spend,
the governance and security
boundaries that you wanna put
around this technology.
If you begin with the right eval framework
and the right experimentation
to get there, results follow.
So definitely recommend
kind of taking a fresh look
at the development methodology as well.
And I'll just say very quickly
I've hinted at some of this,
but we're living those best
practices in our business.
Everything from the CEO mandate through
to every employee in the company.
Leveraging generative AI,
starting with those processes
I talked about before.
Our technical foundation where we've used,
we are a hybrid cloud company
that runs across (indistinct)
our own data centers,
other cloud providers,
building that technical foundation
so we can bring innovation
everywhere that our business needs it.
And then helping to codify
and really understand that ADLC,
which is now the methodology
we use inside of our business,
you know, has been part of our journey.
So real quickly, if you
wanna learn more on ADLC,
I skipped one other project,
Bob, which is our GenAI IDE.
But that's one part of how
we're seeing profound results
in both how we develop code
and how we are getting much
more productive in our business.
And then WatsonX Orchestrate,
which is our agentic
orchestration platform
that runs across environments,
AWS in the data center
and other cloud providers to
bring agentic orchestration
and agent ops to basically any environment
where your business happens.
So with that, I said we'd
have lessons from the leaders
and hopefully that synthesis
that we've done in the
research was helpful.
But I wanna bring over
Mark Murphy, who's the CEO
of Claims Connection Group
to talk about a real world example of
how he's used this technology
to create real advantage in his business.
Mark.
(crowd clapping)
- So MIT meets boots on
the ground, my friend.
- MIT meets boots on the ground.
Sure, I'll take that.
Well, those are great boots.
Those are great boots.
Well Mark, maybe we just start off,
we just talk a little bit about,
we'll get to it in a second.
Talk about your company,
talk about (indistinct)
and how did you get
started on this journey?
- It's a really good story actually.
So I had a construction company.
I've been the insurance
restoration business for years
and decided to move to Texas.
I'm from Minnesota, so just
a redneck moving down south.
And my goal is to help people
and I helped a lot of people
in my construction company,
but 500 to a thousand a
year is not all of them.
So my goal was moving to
Texas is start a new company
and the catalyst was, is I worked
with existing CRM managers
in our industry trying
to recreate the wheel for
our business processes.
So I had eight businesses
trying to get it down to one
and it wasn't working with them.
And one of my young
bucks, he came up to me
and he goes, "Mark,
you ever heard of IBM?"
And he is 26, right?
And I'm like, yeah, I mean,
I know who Watson is, right?
Playing chess back in the 90s.
And I'm like, yeah,
I'll send him an email.
So I sent him an email, I'm not
a tech guy, never have been.
But what happened was, it was process,
which is what we're all about, right?
We're all about process.
So it's like, okay, how could
I help all the people instead
of one or 500 or a thousand?
And so long story short
here, I sent the use cases
and IBM got back to me
and I started with it.
I had a lot of use cases, right?
I'm trying to do a 48 state
level deal immediately.
And I told him three to five
years and an IBM came along.
One of my first experiences as A CEO was,
where's my money stuck?
Where I spend the most money
and where's my throttle?
And for mine it was estimating.
So we automated estimating
immediately within three weeks.
And so my average estimator
could do eight a day
and we can now do 244
per user license per day,
which saved me 14,000 bucks a day.
That's gets me excited.
Not only am I saving money,
but I'm helping more people
and that's the biggest part.
And so the next question is,
who has an insurance policy here?
You didn't raise your hand.
No.
So (indistinct) is a...
So what happened was as we started
to build out an internal
BAW for our processes
and it spun off into
three different companies,
built strictly off IBM technology.
And so (indistinct)
was the insurance deal.
So what happens, what's the next throttle?
The next throttle is in my
company is I am the one that has
to, if you have a claim, I give
you not advice, but I mean,
'cause I can get an E&O claim,
which is errors and omissions.
Okay? And so that
throttles up to me, right?
Well now on a thousand
person level, still busy,
but now do nationwide.
I can't do that.
So like, okay, let's use agentic AI.
And so we built a private AI using
Orchestrate and WatsonX AI.
And what it can do is, is where I spend,
I have to have the call,
"Hey, here's the claim,"
I'm talking to you, right?
You're calling me. That's a
half an hour of just this.
And it's like, here's the advice
Roger, let's do something.
- Yep.
- Okay, so that's an hour
a day, right? Eight a day.
Now we can do it in two minutes
without any interaction.
And they're getting the
same advice as I would give.
So now we're able to help a lot of people.
- That's fantastic.
So I think this notion of the merger
of process and technology,
that's kind of the core,
the boots in the ground and IBM,
if you just think of so many people,
every business has a process about,
how urgent do you feel like this topic is?
If you said to other leaders in the room,
how urgent is it to
really tackle this now?
- You are two years late
if you haven't started yet.
- I think that says it pretty
well. And I agree with that.
I agree with that.
Talk about the implementation itself.
What are some of the
challenges along the way?
How did IBM help you through that?
How much did you have to
help yourself through that?
Talk about that journey.
- It was me, I'm organic,
no software, you know,
I utilize software to make
money and help people of course.
But with the IBM journey and trying to,
I mean anything when
you're talking one state
to 48 to global, you're there.
The part where we often,
as me it is like, it was tough.
I took 18 months off and did
not make income to do this.
And I sat with engineers,
expert labs, client engineering,
and I had a lot of use cases
and we had to put 'em all together.
I learned a lot of
things about my business
and my processes during that
and a lot of times I've been like, man,
I shouldn't even be up here right now
'cause I'd have an island
if I would've done it correctly to start.
And that's on this level to your point is
we gotta, it's always this,
it only has to be this
to start.
Where's your money suck,
eliminate that thing,
then you get pumped up
and then you keep doing it, right?
And you can go down to
organic level sending emails
and all the other things, right?
But how do you help more people?
How do you make it easier
and more effective?
- We were prepping for this.
I love the phrase, where's
the suck as a mental model
for figuring out where to
focus in your business.
'Cause you gotta back to
what I was talking about.
It's putting the effort into the things
that are gonna have the real economics
and then that means that
each use case gets easier
and easier along the journey.
But you start with one
where you know it's gonna be
a moneymaker or at least there's a strong
belief will be a moneymaker.
- Saving money's just as good
as making money, my friend.
- It's true.
And by the way, now
you're doing both right?
You're able to then serve more customers
so you're making more
money and you're doing it
far more productively.
So you're doing both.
- Money's a byproduct
of doing things right.
- Yeah.
- You know, that's all it is.
- And then just as a side,
just if you think about Mark's
journey kind of prepping
for this, this is like a use case
that this technology is fantastic for.
If you think about understanding
process in one state
and then all the variants
across 48 different states,
that's the type of pattern that I think
for a human being is
really almost impossible
to understand all that complexity,
but it's far easier for this technology.
So it's almost a perfect case study for
how this technology can help with barriers
that just couldn't have
been broken without it.
- Correct.
You know, I mean again,
you're helping more people,
and the same as you help
one you can help a million.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- It's just how do we do that without
hiring more people and
doing all the things
and like again, these new
companies I started with,
IBM is literally built
off this foundation of
where Roger started
this in 2020, you know,
and I'm a perfect byproduct of his vision.
- There were a few other
participants in setting
that vision, but I'll
take a little credit.
I appreciate that.
Mark, if you have to net out though,
I mean, we talked about at the beginning,
like the MIT study went
viral earlier this year.
So many companies haven't gotten
ROI, not just from agentic,
which is obviously even more complex
to implement than traditional GenAI.
How do you look at, just talk about
how do you net out the ROI
and how did you know, you were,
like how did you track
that you were on path to really get value
from this technology along the journey?
Like what are the measures you-
- Very simple, entrepreneur style, right?
90% of businesses fail. That's a fact.
Now you got 95, I watched the MIT study
and I'm like, well I
got 5% less competition.
Very simple.
You know, (laughs) it's what it is.
- So you're much more as an entrepreneur,
you're comfortable with that risk
and potential to fail-
- Don't fail, but fail to try.
- Yeah.
Now we got a lot of people
from larger companies here.
Any advice from...
You work with a lot of
large companies as well.
How do you translate that kind
of entrepreneur mindset into...
- That's our inherent
problem with all of this
is the enterprise level
companies, they move slow,
and you're talking legs
and it's meetings on
meetings and you know,
and it's just like, again, take
a bite of the apple, right?
You're not gonna be able
to embrace the agentic AI
on security level and
everything else immediately,
but find the one piece, do
that and then it compounds.
But it cannot be, hey, we're gonna take a,
I don't want to use big company's name,
large insurance company, okay?
You're not gonna rinse and repeat
and get rid of everything you built.
So what I originally started
with, IBM was BAW workflow
for my own processes.
Then we compound agentic AI on top of that
and we were already moving
good with the BAW, right?
Now we're just getting better.
And I think that's what a lot
of existing enterprise companies have,
is that existing infrastructure
that you're not, I mean,
I would not do it as a
CEO, I wouldn't rinse that.
But if we can amplify
it, which is agentic AI,
then we do that.
- Mark, one big question,
you touched on this a little bit before,
but like, people talk about governance
and security for this technology.
And for you personally, those E&O claims,
like for people that aren't, like
if the AI accidentally gives
your customers bad advice,
you are financially-
- Me personally, (indistinct).
- Yeah, your wellbeing is at risk.
How did you get comfortable
with this technology?
Say I can believe in it
such that you can take
that personal risk or you
avoid that personal risk?
- I don't avoid any personal risk.
It always lands on me and my friend.
So what I did during this process
of building out (indistinct)
which is our policy reader,
you know, again, this is not,
so I drop into all the large
language models, everything,
all the deals, including building our own.
But what I trust, I don't,
large language model,
I'm not gonna drop company names,
but it has to be the right
prompt to give the right advice.
And that's the biggest issue
on compliance and HEPA.
So and for our story, my story is to build
that product to where I felt comfortable
where I'm not gonna lose my home is
building the agentic AI with IBM.
- Mark, maybe one last
question for this audience.
You've went through this journey.
If you had one thing that
knowing what you know now,
is there anything you'd change
or what was one piece of advice
you'd give for the people
that might be earlier in their journey?
- I feel like I'm a wild
veteran at this thing,
which I'm not.
You don't have to be the
smartest kid in the room.
I'm 2.3 GPA from a trade school, okay?
And we figured it out, right?
It's you find the right
people to work with,
you find the right business
partner, which is IBM.
They don't pay me to be here, by the way.
But like my business
model is to help people
and the reason I'm sitting here is
because I want other
people to help people.
So if you have a question
on where to start
or how to pitch your boss,
what I find is the biggest,
I've been to all the events
and a lot of people come up after I talk
and they got sent here for their boss.
"What do I do?"
"Well, I got all this data,
Mark, I come back to the CEO
and he says I'm crazy."
Well, you are crazy. You
understand where you're at.
But again, to the point
where does the money suck?
CEO's gonna love that.
You know, you gotta hit
from that perspective,
which is hard to do as an employee
sitting here in the crowd.
- But yeah, I mean I think
it's phenomenal advice
and goes right to the
back to the beginning.
I mean, this technology
exists to create value.
We have so many other
categories of technology
that have been much more mature
before you had to wake up and adopt them.
And so we knew the
proven patterns of value,
but this technology is moving so fast
and so important that you have
to find the suck in your business.
- You gotta put the tile
to the pavement now.
- Okay, to get going.
Alright, well listen,
Mark, I wanna thank you for
joining us on stage here.
It's a pleasure to have you as a partner.
(crowd clapping)
And I'm gonna pass it off to Vishal
to introduce our next
client from Apollo Tires.
Thanks Vishal.
- Thank you Roger.
Okay, yeah.
So I was saying (indistinct)
from Apollo Tires
is gonna go fairly
technical about how they're using Agentic
at their organization.
But before we do that,
I'm gonna spend a minute
or two on AWS and IBM.
AWS and IBM.
It's really a story about momentum.
Together we've built one
of the strongest alliances
in the industry.
We've got 12 partner of the year awards
for innovation, design
and client collaboration.
At the center of this is
IBM's AWS's premier client
consulting partner,
powered by 25,000 trained AWS consultants
over 200 locations and
34 delivery competencies,
including agentic and manufacturing.
And we made strategic
acquisitions over the years.
Redhat for example, it
brings open source innovation
that integrates very well with AWS.
We just acquired Texture so
that we can help our clients
with target operating models.
Similarly, new (indistinct)
they bring cloud native
and managed services for our clients.
But the real impact is in client,
how we deliver to our clients.
We use our garage method
to deliver 75% better
outcomes for our clients.
I'll give you an example.
Delta Airlines, they came to us.
They wanted us to transform
their passenger experience
and flight ops.
Together we modernized, containerized,
and we go to cloud native about 600 apps.
Not only did the clients save money,
but they became a lot more
agile and a lot more productive.
So the story is really about
acceleration, innovation,
proven by client outcomes.
So when I talk to my clients,
it's becoming very clear
that we are going past the AI hype cycle.
Clients are making strategic decisions,
decisions that will
determine whether AI remains
a set of experiments or it
becomes something more productive
that gives real value to the clients.
IBM's Institute of Business
Value, we did a study
and the results were very striking.
Only 15% of our clients
right now qualify as leaders.
When I say leaders, I mean that they have
gone past the pilot mode.
They're actually embedding
workflows into their applications
and processes and they're able to
get the ROI that they need.
So basically AI is not a gadget for them,
it's something that is
producing ROI for them.
So the foundation of this
success is really data.
A lot of our clients are
starting to invest in data
because they know that
without clean connected data,
the promise of AI will never be possible.
The third thing I'm seeing is agentic,
80% of execs are making a
huge investment in agentic
because they expect the
workflows to get re-engineered
and for the agents to produce
a lot of productivity.
And finally, of course you need security.
And that's why our
clients are spending a lot
of money on security.
But how do you do it right?
The instinct is go to
go from right to left.
I would say let's not do that.
Let's go from left to right.
Set your strategy first.
Align it with your goals,
then come up with initiatives
that align to your strategy.
Then you start to embed
AI into your workflows
and then you have to of course
take care of your talent,
upskilling culture.
And then you bind all of
this together with security
and compliance because you
have to make sure that the AI
that you are putting in
your systems can be trusted.
So in terms of value, it
doesn't come all at once.
It comes in layers.
The first layer, of course
is productivity based agents.
We've all seen summarization tools,
chatbots, all those things.
The productivity of
that comes only when the
employees adopt them.
The second is re-engineered workflows.
That's where when you
start to combine AI, GenAI
and automation to really
change the workflows
and get value out of them.
The third of course is Nirvana.
It's ambient AI where
AI is almost everywhere
and then you are able
to use real time data
to accomplish big things.
So one of the clients who's
really doing this really well
is Apollo Tires.
And I'm gonna invite (indistinct) to share
how he's using agentic
AI in his organization.
(indistinct)
- Thanks Vishal.
I hope I'm (indistinct) everybody.
How's everybody doing?
So exciting time, exciting
keynote if you attended today,
and before I talk about the
tech part of it, let's try
to understand why is it even important.
What is a problem that
we are trying to solve?
Apollo Tires are well-known
brand within the Asia Pacific.
We are heavily invested in US market.
$3.5 billion company, 20,000 employees,
complex product group.
We are across all the segments,
passenger, farm, trucks,
off-roading, two-wheelers.
We have two brands, Apollo and Vredestein.
Vredestein is a premium brand,
which you can find here in US.
In the farm segment, we
have Apollo Tires in US
all across the Europe.
So very large organization,
complex processes.
To solve these things
what you need are again,
some exciting technologies.
In fact, the word
exciting excites me a lot.
Matt spoke a lot about it today.
So what we did, we started our
tech journey four years back
when we started moving all our workloads,
manufacturing everything onto the cloud,
our manufacturing execution
system, SCADA systems,
VMIs, most of those
things, production systems
of entire ERP, SAPs on the cloud.
The best thing what we did is
that we removed the data silos.
After we removed the data
silos, the first thing
that we did is we
created a giant data lake
onto the cloud itself.
The objective was that anybody
who is using the data
should have a trusted data,
single source of truth, no more silos.
We have seven manufacturing facilities.
Earlier the data was within
the manufacturing facilities.
If you're familiar with the
manufacturing processes,
the SCADA as I'm talking about,
they store the data into the historians.
Terabytes of data.
We do a lot of quality checks
using the X-ray images,
again, terabytes of data.
Today we have more than
400 terabytes on my S3
and nearly eight terabytes
in my data warehouses,
which are built on Redshift and Aurora.
What do I do with all this
data? Terabytes of data.
What insights can I get?
There is no point in
having all this data if you
can't make a meaning out of it.
If you can't answer a single question.
The result was we were
using traditional BI,
more than 500 reports.
Everybody who wants
something, they'll come to us.
We are the bottleneck. Can
you create this report to me?
I'll take 15 days, understand
the business process,
deliver one report.
Then they'll say, "Oh, I also wanted
another question to be answered.
Here's another report for you.
Here's another version of the report."
So these things pile
up and this is going on
with everybody in the traditional
business intelligence reporting.
So what we did is that
the good part with LLM is
that now you can use the LLM
to convert whatever the
human is saying into
the natural language part
of that, into a SQL query.
I can very easily execute that
SQL query into my database
and then get the answer instantly.
There is no need of any
BI, my business users,
my CIOs, CXOs, everybody can
just use this to find out
what was the sale as of
today morning in real time.
What was the total dispatch done today?
Has it reached to the customer
on time? What is the OTIF?
How is my productivity happening
in the manufacturing plant?
My IoT devices which are
directly talking to my data lake,
instantly give me the
insights of the plant.
What have I manufactured today?
Which machine was down for how much time?
I know the latency
between my manufacturing
to the warehouse, to the
dispatch to the customer.
Has it reached on time or not?
How many orders have I missed?
Till now everything was
within the batch process.
A delay of four hours,
sometimes 24 hours when
it comes to the BI tool.
So what we did, a very simple thing.
We put the LLM on the top
of my entire data lake,
this is just a POC.
What we have done and the
results are phenomenal, amazing.
Everybody who saw from the business,
they were absolutely blown out.
A very simple thing.
What they can do is fire a
command and then get the results.
Not just that they can store
the sessions, they can go back
to the session, have
the context as a memory.
They can also generate
the charts out of it.
And if the default charge generated
by my system is not good
enough, they can say, oh,
I want the same data in the pie chart.
No, no, I want in the line chart.
From the previous query I want to further
and refine and drill it down.
So what we did, which is this,
so what we did, laser pointer.
Okay, hey.
So I have two data warehouses I mentioned.
One is Amazon Aurora and
the other one is Redshift.
Dependent on what kind
of data I want to store
and what kind of analytics I want to do.
While Redshift is very good in terms
of the columnal storage,
large data storage, indexing
and creating the UDF
or the procedures are
a little complicated.
So that's where we use Aurora
for some of my use cases.
The data inside the Aurora
we took as the first trial
or the POC, on the top of Aurora,
we simply use the Amazon Bedrock.
And then using the Bedrock,
we created a context model
for at least one of the databases.
There are hundreds of them
and hundreds of tables.
We picked up one of the simplest cases
for the warranty issues of the customers.
Very simple thing we did.
And my users can now query this database.
They can find out what
was the warranty claim,
what was the total percentage,
how many dealers are claiming what?
What are the product failures?
They can very easily find it out
rather than using a BI tool.
Go back.
I'm storing all these sessions
into my Amazon OpenSearch.
With all the context, user can
store X number of sessions.
They can come back, retrieve a session,
see what they did last time.
On the top of that, they can
again run a context query.
The second thing is I want
to use the data which is stored in S3
other than the Amazon
Aurora, as I mentioned,
400 terabytes of data.
I want to expand it not
just to my structured data,
but even to my unstructured data.
My marketing says I have thousands
and thousands of marketing materials.
There are insights from
the marketing agencies,
there are PDF files.
What do I do with that?
It's hard to make a meaning out of it.
The simplest thing, what I can do is
that I can run an LLM on the top of that
using the same tech stack
and then my marketing team
can get the entire summary of
what is happening with the competitors,
with the other agencies within the market.
My R&D says, I want
to understand my
engineering drawings better.
My shop floor says that I want
to solve a problem when
the machine is broken.
I have to read through the manual
and see what exactly has to be done.
So this whole thing now
just a POC has opened
so many avenues for me
to deliver on the top
of my entire 400 terabytes of data lake.
The xray images that I have,
when a warranty issue comes,
I go and analyze that.
What happened wrong with
that particular case?
Was it manufacturing?
Was the manufacturing at fault?
Was it like the post manufacturing,
the curing process was there,
was there a foreign
particle within the tire
or what exactly happened?
I want to analyze the whole genealogy in
that particular thing and find out
who manufactured, which shift
it was manufactured into,
which assembly line it
was manufactured into.
These questions are extremely complex
and then they take a lot
of time to get answered.
Earlier my R&D team, my
manufacturing team was spending days
to get those answers.
On the similar lines, we
have developed another
prototype using the graph databases
where they can find out the
whole genealogy, the parent
and child of the manufacturing process.
So essentially the results
are extremely exciting,
very positive, very promising.
And the single POC we plan to expand.
We want to take it to the next level,
put it on the entire data lake
and give it to my all the users.
This we call it as the
self-service data lake,
just like the self-service
BI tools people use today.
So there is no need of going to train
to business how to use it.
This is so easy.
The simple user interface
integrated with active directory.
They can go and log in.
I can control who access
what part of the data
and then they can just use
it across all the segments
till the executive level
till the CXO levels.
Zero training ROI from day one.
In terms of if I want to measure some
of the quantitative parts of that,
a simple report if I want to create,
it takes probably 15 days
for me to create a report.
Business will come tell
their problem statement.
I will hire a BA, business analyst
who will understand the problem statement.
The knowledge transfer will happen.
They'll say X will understand Y
and then number of iterations
will create a report,
deliver the report.
And again, they'll do a dry run on that.
Gimme a feedback. I'll define the report.
The whole process can take 15
days to a month depending on
how complex or easy the report is.
Gone is that particular
time. I don't need that.
Business doesn't have to
tell me what they want.
In some parts yes,
because yes, I have to
create a context of the data,
especially when there are multiple tables.
The good part is that when
you create a BI report,
your knowledge is drained.
That BI report is containing your business
logic and the knowledge.
But here now I can store my entire context
and the knowledge within
my data lake itself,
which is my goal as a
single source of truth.
Once I have done that,
my KPIs are uniform across the company.
If my sales says my sales
value is X, my commercial
and my finance cannot say
yes, this is different
because everybody's looking at the same
number across the board.
The reporting time reduces
where my book closing
happened within 10 days.
Now using this thing, I
can have my book closing
and get the answers to what
was my total quarterly sale
or monthly sale within probably
four days to five days.
This is what we are targeting.
So if I want to quantify the benefits,
this slide probably won't be enough
to quantify those benefits.
So that's all I wanted to
share from my insights.
I'll hand it over to Vishal.
- Before I go further, I
have a question two for you.
- Sure.
- So what I see is a lot of
our clients have tech data
or tech debt, process debt, data debt
that really inhibits their AI journey.
I'm guessing (indistinct),
you face some of
that in your organization as well.
So talk to me about how
you overcome those debts
that you have and still
make this possible.
- So interesting.
Again, if you attended the keynote today,
Matt also spoke about exactly same thing.
He spoke about the tech debt
and a lot of agents that he
has introduced AWS introduced
to solve some of these things.
We have very, very simple
rules when it comes
to removing these debts.
So we have a very simple rule.
We want to remove these debts.
When you talk about the
data that I spoke about,
the data silos, that was the
first tech debt we removed.
No more data to be stored
within my on-prem systems,
whether it is x-ray images,
whether it is my historians,
whether it is my transactional
data, my SAP data,
everything must land within my data lake.
One single data lake, which must be used
for all my reporting, all
my analytics, all my AI,
my entire AI layer runs on that.
So that is the first thing we have done
as a future proof thing that we want
to remove the data debt.
When it comes to the tech debt,
we have chosen two tech stacks.
Either we will work on
Python, which works very well
for everything you want
to do web development,
you want to do API,
you want to do fast API
or API in the flask,
or you want to run your
AI on the top of that,
it seamlessly integrates
with all the AI systems.
I want to analyze the data.
I can run it within the
Jupiter, whether I do it in AWS
or if you guys are using Microsoft Fabric,
it runs everywhere.
So that is my second text
stack that I want to use
and remove the tech debt that
no more any other technology.
Probably in some cases,
yes, we use node js
or there are some legacy
applications still running
on .net.
Then my golden rule is
if I can run it on Linux,
that is my first preference.
I'll run it on Linux.
My first preference is
I run it on Graviton.
That reduces my cost by 40 to 50%.
I run Amazon Linux on
Graviton cheapest solution
that you can get in the market.
My second thing is if you
cannot run it on Graviton,
if you need the Intel architecture,
(indistinct) architecture, fine,
I'll give you AMD if not,
then I'll give you Intel.
That's how I manage my cost.
If Linux doesn't work for you, then yes,
I will go for Window that
is the only solution.
So those are some of my
standard rules I have created
that I remove my tech debt.
When it comes to the databases
I'm very clear I will not
run any database on-prem
until it's absolutely needed
for the manufacturing within
the edge, within the plant.
I'll run it on RDS.
If I'm running on RDS,
I'll give you a database,
not the whole server.
Traditionally people had this habit
of buying a separate instance
for everything that they want to do,
where you see multiple licenses coming up.
Again in RDS, if you can
run on PostgreSQL, fine.
If not, then probably if you want MySQL
or something, if not,
it is something that has
to run on Oracle and SQL,
fine, I'll give it to you.
So these are the standard rules that I use
to remove my tech debt.
I hope I've answered those questions.
- Fascinating. Yeah.
So I know we need to get
to our lessons learned.
So I'm gonna take maybe a
couple minutes just to share
with you a couple of the things.
So IBM enterprise advantage,
think of it as a complete toolkit
for you to take your
AI ambitions to reality
and think of it as a three layer cake.
Roger talked about of course,
IBM consulting advantage.
So that brings together
all the tools, assets,
and services for you to take
the entire AI lifecycle.
On top of that, we have
a advantage marketplace,
which is by the way, vendor neutral.
So you can use the tools from IBM, AWS
or other partners so that the solution
that you're building
fits your environment,
not the other way around.
We also include the agentic studio.
It's a development platform
and a hub that has all the
tools assets for you to scale
and optimize AI faster and smarter.
On top of that, of course,
is AI implementation services
so that you can scale your AI
and you can optimize your
AI as you go forward.
So the story really is simple, right?
So it is not about just the technology.
This framework is about
tools, people, processes
that we bring to you so that you are able
to scale your AI journey.
I'll spend only a minute
on the marketplace.
So this marketplace has what
you need in terms of agents.
These agents can be
business agents, they can be
by industry, they are by
SDLC, they are domain.
You can license these from IBM.
And when you do that,
basically you're able
to not start from the scratch.
So it's already half done
though the cooking is half done,
and then you can bake your own
cake from that point onwards.
So at the core,
this really embodies IBM's
asset based consulting approach.
We bring to you packaged
reusable assets that you can use
to bake your own cake.
One last thing.
A lot of people ask me, so how
do I think about AI agents?
Should I think about them
as robots? I would say no.
I would say think of them
as your trusted employees.
Think of your most
trusted employee, right?
So what do you think about them?
They're skilled, they're
dependable, they're coachable.
They have all the access
and they're supervised
when it needs to be.
So your AI agent needs
to be like a trusted
employee, not like a robot.
So what do I mean? So skillset.
So when I'm training my agents,
I'm not training them on a big LLM,
I'm gonna take away domain specific LLM
and I'm gonna use your data
so that I can train them
in the right format, right?
I will use your processes, your methods so
that the agent understands that.
Now when I onboard a agent,
I'm gonna give it access,
privileges, everything like
I would do to an employee.
Nothing more, nothing less.
So it has to be
constrained in that format.
It has to follow your rules.
So whatever the constraints
you have in the organizations,
the rules you have, your
agents have to follow that.
And then it has to be coachable.
So it's not gonna be
perfect on day one, right?
So I should be able to
coach it, give it feedback,
and then of course you have
to work within the parameters
of your risk management
that you have in your company.
And finally, human in the
loop is very, very important.
It doesn't go away.
So I'm gonna go to the lessons
that I think we are gonna share.
The first one, at least for me is
that human in the loop is not optional.
Not yet at least right?
For the sake of enforcement,
for the sake of compliance,
for sake of security, for sake
of your reputational risk,
you need human to be
in the loop right now.
Your agent cannot be fully
autonomous on day one.
You can give it some autonomy
and as the agent proves to
you that it is consistent
and getting more and more consistent,
that's when you give it more autonomy.
But human stays in the loop.
So that's one thing that
I think about it a lot.
What are some of your learnings?
- So the best learning
that came through this is
always start small.
Do A POC.
Of course you can't ignore
the quality of your data.
That has to be a good quality data
that you want to work on.
The POC that we did, I'm happy to share.
And you won't believe within
five days we were able
to get the initial results.
Things are so easy, plug and play
when you use the Bedrock,
the knowledge base
and the search engine
that we are building.
OpenSearch that we are using.
Within 15 days the prototype was ready
and I was able to take it to
my CTO to seek an approval
that this is what we are building.
And after we had the approval that yes,
they're gonna sponsor it,
we can take it forward
as a full scale project
on the entire data lake,
which is a massive project
that is gonna be there.
Sometimes what happens,
business will come,
or probably you will think,
I want to solve the most complex problem
because that is the pain area.
Early wins are very important.
You show the early wins and then
after that you move to the
complex one rather than,
you know, picking the most complex project
and either delaying it,
going for the cost over.
So that is one of the
most important lesson
that I would say you
should follow as a rule.
- I mean, I was very, very
impressed on how you took
a pain point that is so common, right?
And you created a pilot
and you started small
but high impact, you went for early wins.
And that's why I think
you're getting the momentum
that you are.
Well done.
Another thing that I think
about is when you think about
agents, think about the
business outcomes, right?
Don't think about the technical outcomes.
Start with a business world,
right? So is it validate it?
Is it detect, is it a
claims processing agent?
So you have to think about agents
not as something technical.
What is the outcome that
you're trying to achieve
and design the agent around that.
That gets your business along with you
and you get momentum that way.
- Yeah, absolutely right.
Again, I would go back to the keynote.
You can't avoid the agentic framework now.
More and more agents, you
know, are being launched.
The new one that was announced today,
the front end agent rather
than the backend agents.
In one of the use cases, what we did
in a multi agentic framework,
we created two agents.
While one agent is trying to
interpret the natural language
and generate the query,
we created a agent we call
as judge, who is going
to judge whether the query
generated is right or wrong.
For example, when I'm saying
give me the top five products,
has your agent generated
a query which really
gives you top five
or is it giving you top 10 or top four?
How do you know the SQL
generated is right or wrong?
So we pass that to the second agent
to interpret those keywords
and the judge qualifies
and then corrects the first agent.
So these kind of frameworks, if you want,
ideally they should be implemented
and there are very good
articles, whole books on that
in case you are looking
for multi-agent frameworks
on the web, you should go through that.
- Yeah, I'll amplify what
you're saying. Right?
So don't try to make a super agent, right?
Make smaller, specialized
agents who talk to each other
because over time, like I said,
agents have to be coachable.
So if you make smaller agents,
then they get specialized
and they are coachable
and then you can get them
to behave the way you want them to.
So in my mind having
multi-agent, so you think
of it like a planner, a
researcher, an auditor, you know,
different agents who are
working with each other to get
to the outcome that you want.
- True.
- We have less than a minute left,
so I'll let you have the last word.
- Yeah.
See, my suggestion would be
in case you are planning
to build any such thing,
your baseline framework
should be strong enough.
What we did right in this case
was our focus was that fine,
we can catch up with the AI,
but our data layer should be
extremely, extremely strong.
That's where we focused.
Otherwise, what happens when
you develop these things,
the data silos become the pain point.
You do not know which data to trust upon.
You'll run the AI on one
particular data silo will give you
X results, and then you
bring it to the second one
it'll give you y results.
Training becomes a pain point,
retraining has to be done.
So the baseline data layer must be there,
which should be company wide, globally,
dependent on of course
how you're organized.
But then this is the first
thing that we did right.
The second thing was that we focus on more
of real time data.
We heavily invested in the IoT
considering we are a
manufacturing company.
So directly getting data from
the PLCs, from the plants
was our priority and this
has worked very well in terms
of the real time insights.
Then we have a cloud first strategy,
if I can run it on the cloud
I will first prefer to run
my project on the cloud,
which gives me absolute
scalability control over the cost.
And we have converted
the entire CapEx model
into the OPEX model.
So no more heavy investment for on-prem.
So these are some of the golden rules
that I have followed and they
have worked very well for us.
- Awesome. Thank you (indistinct).
So we are out of time,
but Mark, (indistinct)
and I are gonna be on sidelines.
If you have any questions,
we are available.
Please come talk to us. Thank you again.
- Thank you everyone.
(crowd clapping)